Justin hey Walt here with a GameSpot
breaking news update the witcher 3 wild
hunt has been officially delayed until
February 2015 CD projekt red's hotly
anticipated role-playing game the
witcher 3 wild hunt has been delayed
from fall later this year to February
2015 CD Projekt RED management announced
the news today in an open letter to fans
the letter reads ever since we started
working on the third installment in the
witcher franchise it's been our aim to
produce a title that would take our 11
years of experience in creating RPGs and
distill them into a quintessence into a
game that would effectively crown those
years we've created a story that flows
naturally cinematically rendered it an
amazing sound and visuals while
preserving full freedom of choice we
recently reexamined what we had achieved
thus far and faced a choice about the
game's final release date the decision
we made was difficult thoroughly
considered and ultimately clear and
obvious we concluded that a few
additional months will let us achieve
the quality that will satisfy us the
quality gamers expect from us
consequently we've set the release date
of the witcher 3 wild hunt for February
2015 you can read the entire letter on
gamespot and we'll keep you updated as
this story develops